so you guys have been requesting me to
do an updated what's in my bag and it's
so
full so full
so jenna's gonna help me yeah i know
this is what i carry like why that's so
good for your
shoulder but we're gonna go through here
and we're gonna look at some stuff we
have and jenna can judge me great that's
a tripod i know what it is it's your
iphone yes oh my goodness oh
a google glass
next just trying to speed up the process
here ooh sunny
we need these when i'm traveling i wipe
everything
even the people sitting next to me on
the airplane oh this is hot that's
hazardous i'm scared it'll be real
bright i use this uh when i'm taking
selfies yes
nintendo ds xl
what game do you have an address oh
i just got a block i have two blocks on
do you need a block oh okay two two
pairs of sunglasses the vlogging camera
another one of these
i do this one was running a little low
so i threw another one in good because i
always knew them lotion i actually got
this in london this is my personal
favorite because i steal it from you all
the time yeah don't brush my hair it's
curl time powder
oh i actually could use this an organic
straw
they're biodegradable so they're good
for the environment i've got chapstick
exciting another chapstick exciting
another lipstick exciting how did i fit
all this crap and a hyatt key oh 314.
3.141592654 is pie so i like to carry
with me every single charger that i will
need but i don't like to keep it in my
purse look how cute this bag is though
isn't this cute
yeah i got it blew me down oh my god it
blew me so fashionable this is the most
important thing that i actually do with
my purse other than my credit card uh
mophie juice pack this is also another
one of my favorite vlogging cameras so i
need to have this as a backup because
sometimes my other one will die this is
a mini usb which i use to charge my
cameras
this will charge anything that i plug
into it another little charging dock so
i can plug my usb that's exhilarating
this is for the nintendo ds so exciting
to convert the charger i needed that
last night at dinner wi-fi
i love it my friends need to charge once
again
with a microphone it's a blue microphone
that if i need to record some
soundtracks or some voiceovers or some
you know for my album that's coming out
anyway so it's not a rape whistle no
this is an olive clip that i clip onto
my iphone to make it turn into a
wide-angle lens it's probably one of my
favorite things it's a converter that
will convert your lightning cable into a
micro usb so you are going to lose that
no that's why i keep it in here so
quickly i haven't lost it yet you've
only had it for a week
[Music]
week and a half that's all i have well
thank you so much for watching this
updated version of what is in my purse
what is in my what is going to be in
your purse next week
i'll see you guys later thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe be
sure to follow me on all of the social
networking sites and be sure to check
out my sister jenna on our channel with
me jenny okay bye
[Music]